[Musica]
bwana Buonasera Buonasera a
tutti Sono nata in un paesino piccolo
sulle Dolomiti Auronzo di Cadore Adesso
vediamo dovreste vederlo però mi fanno
gli scherzi c'ho le cantautrici
sabotatrice Eccoci qua Auronzo di Cadore
ai piedi delle Tre Cime è un paese
meraviglioso Sono cresciuta a bagno
maria in questo posto Fino all'età di 11
anni e sono figlia di un educatore e una
biologa entrambi amanti del loro lavoro
dell'Arte della natura tanto da lasciare
la pianura dove erano nati una volta
sposati e e trasferirsi su tra le
montagne facendo nascere me mio fratello
proprio lassù e sono anche stata la
fortunata allieva di un di un poeta lui
era Mario Zan de Giacomo sei De Lucio
non lo conosce quasi nessuno però quando
ero una bambina ed ero su alunna alle
scuole elementari di Auronzo aveva già
scritto Quattro libri di poesie e
ricordo
che ci faceva spesso magari non ci
faceva studiare troppa grammatica ma ci
faceva inventare storie poesie e se era
una bella giornata di sole qualche volta
ci faceva chiudere i quaderni
all'improvviso senza dirci niente e ci
portava nel bosco e lì magari ci
insegnava a riconoscere la bellezza
nelle ali di un libellula o nei disegni
di una
corteccia sono
cresciuta con tutto questo e l'ho
ricevuto in dono in eredità ho
cominciato a suonare da piccolissima
tanto che ho scritto la mia prima
canzone
Eh già era scritto ho scritto la mia
prima canzone a 6 anni si chiamava la
bicicletta e già si intravedeva il mio
spirito ecologista A quanto pare e da lì
non ho mai smesso di F
però per molto tempo non pensavo che
questo sarebbe potuto diventare un
lavoro non lo pensavo
possibile facciamo un salto di qualche
anno adesso
sono circa 15-16 anni sono sull'autobus
di linea che mi porta al liceo di
Mogliano Veneto
e è una mattina d'inverno molto
fredda mattina che non dimenticherò più
che ha segnato la mia vita in modo
indelebile
e per una cosa semplice apparentemente
eh Perché a un certo punto dal
finestrino dell'autobus vidi eh vidi
questo vidi un sole Ovviamente questo
non è quello di quella volta che non
c'erano gli smartphone non potevo
fotografarlo Ma insomma un sole rosso
meraviglioso che sorgeva sopra a una
coperta di nebbiolina in un bosco di
pioppi e ricordo che rimasi incantata da
questa visione e poco dopo il mio
sguardo scese sulle automobili che
stavano scorrendo lentamente sulla
corsia opposta al mio autobus tutte
imbottigliate nel traffico dell'ora di
punta ricordo che scrut con lo sguardo
dentro agli abitacoli e mi resi conto
che la gran parte dei Passeggeri aveva
per loop Almeno così mi sembrava uno
sguardo
triste stanco forse anche
arrabbiato Certo La maggior parte di
loro era pressoché indifferente allo
spettacolo che stava andando in scena lì
proprio davanti a loro e lì Feci una
promessa a me stessa un pensiero molto
lucido Io da grande non sarei diventata
così non sarei rimasta indifferente alle
meraviglie del mondo così come alle sue
storture E ho anche immaginato forse
quale fosse la la giornata di queste
persone le ho immaginate magari
magari stavano andando a fare un lavoro
che non amavano magari con un capo che
faceva loro richieste
assurde magari passavano il loro tempo
guardando l'orologio nella speranza che
quelle 8 ore di lavoro finissero il
prima possibile e mi ricordo che feci
proprio il conto ma se 8 ore le
passiamo facendo qualcosa che non amiamo
Nella speranza che Volino il prima
possibile 8 ore ci va bene le dormiamo
poi ci sono le incombenze domestiche la
spesa quanto tempo ci resta per vivere
davvero e così mi dissi che cascasse il
mondo avrei fatto una cosa che mi
piaceva così non continuavo a non sapere
che cosa fare da grande eh E quindi mi
iscrissi a Sociologia La cosa che più mi
garantiva di di fare qualsiasi cosa Dopo
che non sapevo cosa fosse ho ho finito
gli studi In sociologia e ho rifiutato
due contratti a tempo indeterminato uno
in un consorzio di cooperative sociali e
un altro un'agenzia assicurativa e partì
per il Sud America per l'equador dove
passai 5 mesi con le ragazze di strada
di
kito tenevo con loro un laboratorio
musicale
e ricordo che
trasformavamo spesso in canzoni il loro
vissuto le loro ansie le loro sofferenze
e e poi quando quelle canzoni le
cantavamo insieme diventavano una sorta
di inno di riscatto di rinascita E lì mi
resi conto di quanto potente fosse lo
strumento che avevo fra le mani la
musica ricordo anche che poco prima di
ripartire per l'Italia condivisi con
loro la mia inquietudine rispetto a che
cosa avrei fatto da grande continuavo a
non saperlo E loro candidamente senza
indugi anzi anche un po'
piuttosto indispettite dalla mia
incertezza mi dissero ma Erica è chiaro
che devi fare la cantautrice
e quindi una volta tornata a casa
comincia a fare le cose seriamente e a
crederci un musicista di Roma mi propone
di fare una cover band di Johnny
Mitchell cantautrice che mi piaceva
tantissimo forse anche perché all'epoca
avevo la frangetta e la somiglianza era
effettivamente impressionante e ricordo
che dissi di no perché non avrei voluto
guadagnarmi da vivere imitando qualcun
altro volevo cantare le canzoni scritte
da me e così mi circondi di musicisti
capaci di
apprezzare quello che
facevo se faccio quello che faccio è
perché ho ricevuto in eredità molto dai
miei genitori dal maestro Mario dai dal
paese che mi ha allevato E tutto questo
inevitabilmente esce dalle mie canzoni
perché nelle mie canzoni parlo di questo
pianeta dei suoi
abitanti abbiamo suonato alla FAO ma
anche abbiamo tenuto questo primo tour
italiano nelle foreste certificate a su
impatto
ambientale
Ma c'è un'altra eredità che ho ricevuto
in dono dalla natura quando ero piccola
ed ero nel bosco osservando gli alberi e
le formiche le api notai un profondo
senso di comunità del prendersi cura gli
uni degli altri che ho continuato poi a
ricercare a lungo e che ho ritrovato nel
2017 e da lì poi nella direzione del
coro dell'università Popolare di
Treviso cantare in un
coro in quest'epoca storica è un atto
rivoluzionario in un'epoca che ha fatto
della competizione dell'individualismo
del mito della performance della voce
che grida sopra tutte le altre cantare
in un coro presuppone che ci si ascolti
Prima di
tutto è un prototipo di
unità presuppone che si riconosca il
valore del sussurro della misura del
riempire di contenuto le
parole significa sentire quanto è bello
il colore della propria voce mescolato a
quello degli
altri significa sentirsi forti perché
siamo
insieme
e penso che se faccio questo lavoro è
sia per quello che ho ricevuto in dono
in eredità e e penso che riconoscere
questo ci porti anche a chiederci che
cosa noi lasciamo in
eredità quindi riconoscerci grati per
quello che abbiamo ricevuto e
responsabili per quello che
lasceremo da dove si
comincia dall'ascolto di sé
credo
e ci si ascolta cominciando cosa che io
non sto facendo in questo momento perché
come lo sentite da
respirare da fare un bel respiro è il
primo gesto che ci riporta a noi stessi
ed è un gesto che ci
accomuna a tutti gli altri agli esseri
umani ma anche agli animali e agli
alberi e alle piante lo facciamo tutti
quanti forse potremmo ricominciare da lì
e a tal
proposito voglio salutarvi visto che
avete visto gli strumenti È chiaro che
andiamo a parare lì con una canzone che
è che si intitola proprio respira e che
è una canzone d'amore che un albero
canta a un essere umano Nonostante tutto
quello che stiamo facendo su questo
pianeta Sarebbe bello cantarla insieme
se vi va e ad accompagnare
Pal ci sono Enrico Milani al
violoncello e Sergio Marchesini alla
fisarmonica agli arrangiamenti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Scosta le mie foglie come
fossero capelli di un amato e con gli
uccelli tra le foglie
canterò Dammi le tue mani fanne trama
coi miei rami lega un filo a un
desiderio e adesso non pensarci più
e stai con me
vicino a me
respira
respira stai con
me
vicino a me
respira
[Musica]
respira poggia Il tronco al tronco Non
temere la
tempesta della notte sono forte fatti T
dentro
me il tuo sangue limfa la mia limfa le
tue vene siamo soli non conviene Star
lontani come
[Musica]
sei Stai con
me
a me
respira
respira stai con me
vicino a me
respira
respira e stai con me
vicin
a me
[Musica]
respira
respir e stai con me
dicino a me
respira
respira stai con me
vicino a me
respira
respira stai con me
vicino a me
respira
[Musica]
grazie Enrico Milani Sergio Marchesini
viva Ted
Grazie